So actually, using point-slope form this time gave us extra work. If you look at
which 2 points we had, one of these this first one, 0 negative 2000, is in fact
the y interceptor of our graph. Since for slope intercept form we just need to
know the slope and the y quadrant of the y intercept, we could have avoided all
that work we did in the middle, using the point slope form. Instead we could
have just written 500 in the place of m and the spot of b, negative 2000. The
moral of the story is that point slope form is super, super useful in certain
situations. But we need to think critically about which forms of equations we
should use. Thinking not only about what kind of information we have but also
the actual contents and meaning of that information.